I don't think there's any way you could
make life out of just hydrogen you need
other compounds to give you the more
complex chemistry the start of life was
really the start of the first stars
probably about half a billion years
after the Big Bang
deep inside the cores of these early
stars heat and pressure crushed hydrogen
atoms together so powerfully they fuse
creating helium atoms and releasing a
burst of energy over time helium atoms
fuse together to creating carbon
nitrogen oxygen and even heavier atoms
over hundreds of millions of years
ancient stars build up all the elements
that make up our solar system today
including the atoms in your body but in
doing so these stars pay a catastrophic
price
drained of energy the ancient stars
collapse and then explode in a supernova
spreading their chemically rich Stardust
across space the iron in your blood the
calcium in your teeth in your bones
these were created in a supernova
explosion probably different stars that
blew up billions of years ago seeding
the space around them with this stuff we
are the product of not just one stellar
explosion but many cellar explosions and
the atoms in our left hand probably came
from a different star than our right
hand the carbon nitrogen oxygen and iron
all of that was only created in stars
and the only way you could get here on
earth is that those stars exploded and
that material was later amalgamated in
our solar system
blasted through space these complex
atoms now pepper the clouds of gas that
are nurseries of new stars and 4.6
billion years ago one particular cloud
begins to collapse under its own gravity
and our Sun ignites much of the ancient
star dust is sucked into the Sun never
to be seen again
but the leftovers clump together to form
comets asteroids planets and eventually
life
I actually think of myself as a very
complicated rock I am made of things
like iron and copper and manganese when
you sit down on a mountainside and
you're there with a rock
those are your cousin's too thanks to
ancient supernovas the earth forms with
all the atoms needed to create both
rocks and life but what is it that
distinguishes us from a piece of granite
there are essentially three main parts
to a living organism you've got to have
some metabolism or some kind of system
of chemical reactions that powers your
life you've got to have some kind of bag
or sack that walls you off your internal
systems from the outside environment and
thirdly you've got to store some kind of
blueprint some kind of description of
yourself three things a power source a
protective sac and the plans for making
more protected power sources DNA is the
plan it's a long molecule built up from
small units called nucleotides DNA
contains the instructions for how to
build the cell's protein engine using
small molecules called amino acids DNA
also tells the cell how to make lipids a
fatty molecule that forms a perfect
protective sac and that's all there is
to it you have the basic form of life a
cell